well I grew up with a Chinese mom and it
was extraordinary actually because I
didn't know anyone I was a New York
actress and had come out to Hollywood
and for me you know Franz and Tsai and
Lisa and Q were not just auntie's but
they were these extraordinary Asian
actresses that had paved the way and I
was in all but Q she she just has such
warmth and was a but we were able to
connect immediately and I didn't have
any problems whatsoever in you know
feeling like she was my mother and I
think that has a lot to do with casting
and and in Wayne's directions you know
in in helping us really bond on on a
level where we didn't have to even talk
about it because I think as Asian women
in America especially or even in London
or we have all experienced a lot of the
same types of struggles the same types
of issues you know with our own parents
the cultural and gap and the
generational gap and so we just I don't
know I all I remember was for my first
film it was an extraordinarily easy
process
I'm sure Wayne doesn't feel that way but
you know for me it was I was flying high
because I was a huge fan of the book and
I remember having read Amy Tan's book
when I was on a beach somewhere in
Hawaii and thinking if they ever made
this into a movie I just wanted to be a
part of it no matter what whether I was
a PA or it didn't matter I I you know I
guess that
part of the secret is you just manifest
something to come true